angularity probably welcomed the chance
to take a bit of a break from the usual
political disagreements and celebrate a
positive the 65th anniversary of
Germany's foreign public broadcaster
Deutsche Welle at the official ceremony
the Chancellor stressed the need for
reliable information in an age of
distortion and propaganda we can say
that Dorabella is a success story in the
name of the entire government I'd like
to offer you our heartfelt
congratulations keep plugging away and
doing good work but you can celebrate a
bit today as well Cynthia Merkel took
time to learn about some of DW s
initiatives designed to combat
misinformation and fake news that's one
of many things that has changed since
TWU first went on-air in 1953 is the
Deutsche Welle
in the early days DW only broadcast in
German and via radio today it's become a
global media player employing
journalists from 60 different countries
in Berlin and Bonn DW has come a long
way back then it was just German and
just shortwave these days we have 30
languages and use all the media under
the Sun TV radio social media online
whatever you want so you can say that
things have changed radically first-hand
information remains as important as ever
DW correspondents fire reports from all
over the world well it's the Middle East
Africa or the u.s. more than 150 million
people use DW content every week
congratulations poured in from various
corners of the globe congratulations to
Deutsche Welle for 65 great years here's
to the next 65 I wish you all the best
always stay objective and up-to-date
greetings to Deutsche Welle
for the 65 years of excellent service in
providing news and information to people
around the world may at length the
German parliament plan to increase
funding for DW as a way of promoting the
values of an open society with that
promise
the Chancellor departed back to the
daily political fray Deutsche Welle will
continue reporting on this and other
topics fairly and independently